you said one theater was playing the
film for over you yeah I was peeking
yeah I I heard about it like I was I was
kind of shocked that was somebody so one
of the guys who was actually on the crew
in India he he called me up I don't he
called me or emailed me he was like he
was like hey he's like Humber duh I just
saw your poster here and it's still up
and it's their plane to film and I was
like I was late now you're full of it I
say come on man he's gonna play that
film for more than a year and he sent me
like a little picture and it was up in
the theater and I was like damn I said
they're playing my film it's been over
here so so I was like I'm so I was I
decided to take a trip to go see clay
what's the story here like why why do
people like it and and and yeah so it
was it was a pleasant surprise the other
pleasant pleasant surprise was that that
first film actually made it to a lot of
sources that I didn't know about so this
is the funny that this is the funny
story so so I sold the theatrical rights
okay so I got money for theatrical
rights and that's where we made our
money for but we didn't sell the
television rights ok so we're shooting
the Black Russian up in the mountains
and there's only two channels okay and
on one of the public channels they're
playing awkward decision and this is
crazy so my crude might get the makeup
guy he was he got sick so he was the
only guy who was laid up in the hotel
and he was watching this and he sees my
film and he in in in India I was
interesting because they just assume
you're like a you're since this is a
film that you're starring and they just
assume like oh yeah he's a well-known
actor so he just saw it he goes oh
there's another one of amber's films
cool it's on TV so he he recorded on his
cell phone and so he said hey your films
playing as to my films playing what you
talking about this is my first film I
how come I filmy playing he goes no your
film is playing so I go buh show me so
he recorded in my film the first film
was actually playing and so then we
contacted the the the station we said
hey how did gave me the film and they
were like
we you know they they just didn't answer
the question so so that was cool
you